what is going on everybody and welcome
to part two of the reinforcement
learning with stable bass lines three
tutorial series in this video we're
going to be talking about saving loading
and tracking the performance of your
models
so this is the code that we left off on
we definitely learned that something is
happening when we train it for x number
of steps the problem is how many steps
do we train for and as we saw for sure
with a2c i didn't even look through the
ppo but we definitely saw where
performance at one point was actually in
the positives but it ended at 100 000
steps with a reward in the negatives so
how do we like deal with this so so
that's what we're going to be focusing
on uh here so first off uh we will go
ahead and we will import os and then
we're going to specify a models
directory and this will just be we'll
make models
models
slash and in this case depending on
which one we're using so in this case
we're using ppo so first for now i'll
just say ppo but if we change the
algorithm change change that name don't
be like me and forget i'm sure i will
so that's modelsdirt and then we'll also
have a loggeder
for whoops i didn't mean to run that
i have to what what have i done
logder equals logs
so
uh so once we've specified those we want
to make sure they exist so if not os dot
path dot exists
and
models der we want to os dot make durs
models
der
and then we're going to do the exact
same thing for the log
directory so paste paste cool so that'll
make them if they don't already exist
these lines are totally fine
and now what i'd like to do is set time
steps so this could be
in the form of a thousand time steps or
ten thousand it really is going to
depend on like how quickly does your
environment step in my opinion so this
just comes down to how free essentially
how frequently do you actually want to
save your model
so for now i'm going to also comment
this out because this was to actually
run it
and we'll get to that on the load here
in a little bit but for now what we want
to address is
training and saving so
so in this case let's say we're going to
train every ten thousand steps you can
change this to be five thousand ten
thousand
two thousand five hundred whatever
whatever the heck you wanna use
um
put that number in i'll go with ten
thousand since that's relatively quickly
so let's say what we really want to do
and we'll actually make a constant here
time steps we'll say 10
000.
so model learn for those time steps and
then we'll say for i in range and then
how many time steps do you want to do so
in reality we might actually make this a
wow true loop but just so it'll be easy
for me to kind of compare the two well
again we'll be comparing a2c and ppo
here so i'll just limit it in some way
but for i in range 30 what we're going
to do is model.learn for that many time
steps
now if we just leave it this way the
model will reset every time the number
of time steps that it's like already
taken the model object i mean so every
time you do model.learn it would reset
the time steps that it's at but to stop
that we can say reset
num
time steps and we'll set that to be
false and then we'll also set a tb log
name
and again that will set that to be ppo
um
i feel like we need to have like a
constant probably
um
i think we'll be okay with with two
places to edit but if we add any more i
think i should
we should probably have a variable for
that but anyways whatever model.learn uh
so yeah so the so this reset time steps
will help both with the output that we
see in the console but also in the
tensorboard itself
so model.learn and then basically all
we're going to add is model.save and
we'll use an f string here
models underscore oops
we wanted to use those variables models
dir
slash
and then in this case it will be uh
we're just gonna save uh time steps
times
i
so we'll say
um
whoops not a capital i
dude
there we go so go ahead and save that
so now
essentially this will be time step zero
uh the first time through and in fact
maybe we'll do a range
one to thirty to make this actually
actually accurate otherwise we'll be ten
thousand steps off
so model that save so now it will save
that model every 10 000 steps so i'll go
ahead save that and in fact i think we
probably want to run this
in its own little console so we'll go
ahead and run this
python3 p2
uh save dot pi let's make this
a wee bit larger
and let's go ahead and run that make
sure we don't hit any errors
so far so good
okay and that's off that is training uh
our model for
ppo
now what i'm gonna go ahead and do is
let's just shift
uh i'll put this over here i guess so
i'll move that over
i wish it told you somewhere in that
output what type of model it was but
that's okay so we got ppo training now
i'm going to go ahead and toss in
uh a2c to kill two birds one stone at a
time here so let's make sure that we
make all the changes that we're supposed
to make ooh find and replace probably
would have made sense but that's okay
uh a2c
uh a2c wasn't there one more spot yes
there was
not that
it'd be an interesting model
uh okay so i think
i think we're all set we'll go ahead and
save that let's confirm
that uh we got models or logs so this
will be tensorboard here models ppo
so yeah we have our ten thousand twenty
thousand and thirty thousand steps
models already in there
um whoops
and
i think we're good so let's just double
check make sure i didn't screw anything
up in fact let's go ppo
found that one
it's a good thing we didn't do a find
and replace isn't it
anyways okay cool so now whoops now
we'll save
and let's go ahead and i will run that
one as well so open in terminal python
3
p2
save dot pi
so again this should be running for a2c
in our case so again we'll make it a
little bigger
and i will wait for that to at least
start to output something for us let me
check a2c cool
and let's go ahead and check logs
logs is empty
why would logs be empty
is it possible
why would logs be empty maybe it's every
hundred thousand steps is that what it's
going to do to me
i would think it would update the logs
every 10 000 steps
oh
i know what i've done okay
so i forgot to
in model i
told you we weren't going to be adding
anything else but we are
so so in here we're going to say
tensorboard
tensorboard
underscore log equals log der
and then this is the tb log name
dang it okay so
okay i'm gonna break these two that are
training right now
uh and come back over here i just want
to clean everything up so actually i'm
just going to delete
that
okay coming back here a2c a2c cool i
wish i would have checked that earlier
anyways let's rerun that so this will be
a2c going and we'll make sure that we're
actually
logging this time
okay that's training we'll come over
here well let's confirm before we waste
our time shall we
so a2c underscore zero cool models a2c
very well
okay so
now what i want to do is
switch this to ppo
copy
paste
paste
paste and just to be sure a2c very good
we don't have a2c
and will we run ppo now
i'll slap this over here also a little
curious um
nvidia s am i curious where i'm at
gpu-wise
okay my gpu
yeah we're comfy uh thanks puget so
um
okay so now we have our things training
we should have tensorboard logging
happening so now to actually view the
tensorboard what we'll do is uh
do actually we need to be in that
directory
so we'll come down here
open a terminal
and we'll go
uh tensorboard
logder logder equals logs
very well
so
okay so here although the graphs are
very very small admittedly let's make
this
a little bigger
so the main graph that you're probably
going to care about the most is the
reward average okay um and in this case
ppo is our blue and a2c is our orange so
you probably care about the the average
reward the most that is typically the
thing that we're trying to create here
but the length of the episode also
can carry quite a bit of significance um
and maybe more on that later uh we'll
see
so ppo blue a2c
is
orange okay so what i'm going to do i
think is i'll make i think i can do this
no that's the wrong button i never
remember which one which ones are the
right buttons so i'm going to let these
things train for the 300 000 steps
hopefully i got that right
it should take somewhere before that we
should be able to solve these models
these are very simple models
okay
obviously this is still training and i
will continue to let it go for the 300
000 steps but eventually we'll get to
300 000 and either way while you're
training like i said typically you're
going to probably be using a wow true
loop
rather than you any known ending so now
what we want to do is looking at our
reward mean we might say okay we want to
take ppo at
you know maybe
i don't know which one will we do 180 or
maybe even 175 but we wouldn't have that
saved so it'd either be 170 000 or 180
000 either one we can just grab one of
those let's say we want to load that and
run that also interestingly enough i'm
kind of surprised that uh
we've actually seen we actually see a2c
overtaking ppo this is not
that's not nothing is what i've expected
so far in this series like i expected
um our random agent in part one to be
way more wild but actually our random
agent part one was i think better than
the 100 000 age
that's just like what the heck man
trying to make a tutorial here
um let's go look at some of these
metrics though so
one thing that
should be pretty clear by looking at
these um they are different algorithms
so
take these take this with a grain of
salt but in general the reality or the
thing that i was hoping to be able to
show even with the reward here is but
you can also see it with the reward um
ppo is a smoother algorithm
in general it does it doesn't have as
much volatility
and one thing you will grow to really
hate as you train these reinforcement
learning algorithms is how volatile they
can they can become right um especially
like when i was doing ddpg for example
with the robot dog
um it was very frustrating to have a
model learn learn learn learn learn and
then just tanks it just explodes and
it's like no good anymore
it's like
it just it really guts you so um
in general i like something that is a
little smoother and we can see that
basically in all of these other metrics
like entropy loss
all the all basically all of these
metrics across the board
um ppo is the smoother metric and so for
that reason it is a little more less
stressful to use something like ppo also
in general the performance is much
better
in this case it is comical to see a2c is
actually is it still winning it is still
winning
real hard
okay
live demos so the other thing to think
about too is
a lot of models can be dictated by
just randomness so where did you
randomly initialize and where did you
start taking steps from there so you can
do two things you can either set your
random seed specifically or i kind of
just like to just run a few models
randomly like to test truly test a model
test your environment i would run like
three to five
something like that i've seen huge
variation in exactly the same code and
if and in fact maybe what i'll do before
we leave it'll probably be an exact
match but before the end of this this
tutorial um i'll run one more ppo and i
mean in fact we can just run it um
i think we can get away ppo maybe make
the models dirt could be a dash two
and actually i don't want to overload
the gpu so i'll wait until one of them
is done but i'll show you at least
another tensorboard before this is over
um and you can hopefully see some of the
variants my guess anyways these
environments so basic that maybe there
won't be much but anyways let's get to
loading and kind of seeing one of our
examples in action so for example let's
say we want to take ppo
and i forget already what was a good ppo
one which one is ppo it's our blue
so let's take ppo at
180 000.
so while things are training we probably
want to see where we're at along the way
because again you'll probably wind up
doing it for just a while true loop and
you might want to actually visually see
it so sometimes you'll see the reward is
what you want or maybe the episode
length is what you want but nothing
beats visually seeing it
so again for example with the
robot dog
sometimes the reward looks really good
but then you load it up and either one
the uh the actual agent is somehow
defying the laws of physics like it has
found an actual like bug in the
environment which is
pretty common
or two maybe it's doing something really
dumb that will never be recovered from
so one example that i've seen again from
the robot dog scenario is it would like
jump and do like this kind of roll but
get stuck on its back and it just it was
probably never going to get out of that
that was a really short term kind of
gain
in reward but then actually recovering
from that i've never seen it happen it's
possible that it could like jump and
roll and then jump and roll and then
jump and roll or something like that but
um in general it's good to see it
visually so you have an idea of like
what's actually going on in your
environment uh to cause that reward even
though it might look good on paper in
practice it might not look good at all
so so we want to see what's going on so
to do that we still need our environment
we do need a model
but we're going to use our
one of our saved models so i'm going to
copy the models dir
paste it over here
and the first thing that we want to do
is we're going to specify our model path
model path and that will be
um
that will be
the uh we'll make that an f string and
it will be
models der and then slash whatever that
file name is in this case we'll do 170
000.zip that one was looking good at
least to start
and now what we want to do is actually
load that model so we're going to say
model equals
and this will be ppo dot load and we
will load in the model path and then we
specify the environment so to just be m
vehicles m
now we want to actually run with the
model so
episodes 10 that's totally fine we get
the observation yeah yeah cool cool
basically what we want to do is swap out
this action here so we're going to cut
this out and we're going to say we want
to take an action now what is that
action going to be
so to make that action we're going to
say action equals model dot predict
and actually uh it's gonna be action and
then we'll just say like underscore it
in this case it also the model that
predict is returning um some states so
if you are using we're not i'm not
touching this right now but
if you're using a recurrent algorithm
this will this will be of use to you um
but for now we're not doing that so we
really only care about what is the
action so we're going to say
models.predict or model.predict rather
and that observation so then we'll do
the step based on our actual model's
action we will get all of this other
information
um
and then basically continue the loop so
let's go ahead and save that and we can
run that
maybe
yes okay
so here we have i guess because i've
changed the name it's all itty bitty let
me fix that
beautiful so here we can see our actual
model in action this is our ppo model um
so the episode length
is starting to make a little bit of
sense now
it's not terrible right it's not
crashing but the goal is to land in
between these two flags and
it's definitely not doing that right
right now
but this is better than random and it's
better than the 10 000 model but clearly
we need to possibly continue training so
let's go ahead and check
let's see here if anybody got even
better no our best model
in this case was actually around maybe
190 but also interestingly ppo and e2c
performed identically
it's this is so frustrating yeah you do
like definitely ppo is supposed to win
here
i can't believe this and ppo also just
turned to
to crud by the end this is hilarious
um so what i think i'm gonna do now is
i'm gonna train
i'm gonna train like
i guess we'll do we'll do another run
for each of them to be fair so i'll run
another ppo and another a2c but also
while we're at it let's go ahead and
check an a2c at
i guess 190k
so we'll come over here
we will oh it already died it died
before i could do it so we'll change
this to 190 and then we'll change this
to a
a2c
we'll change this to a2c a2c cool
uh and let's just go ahead and import
ppo and a2c we don't need to be
switching that around every single time
cool cool run that
wait for it
so here's our a2c
it looks pretty good too it's very
comparable to our
i think that i don't think we ever saw
ppo actually succeed in any way
this is interesting when i was like
making the text based version of this
tutorial this is this is like nothing
like i was seeing
it's funny um
classic
so okay so now what i want to do is i'm
going to train both of these again and
maybe maybe i'm going to walk away while
i train these so i'm going to do maybe
i'll do like a million steps just
because i am
surprised at our results thus far
so
cool so what i'm going to do is we'll
just
kill this
and p2 save let's do models do ppo
so the only thing if i want to run a
bunch of ppos would be here
and maybe what i'll do is import
time let's get real fancy about this
super fancy
i will do an int time dot time cool
and
[Music]
30
let's do do i really want to do a
million times
kind of
i kind of want to see the
a better result here
what was it so uh ten thousand so we'll
do a hundred time steps
and i think maybe i'll do like two and
two
so let's save that
p2 save so what i'll do is come over
here i'll run p2 save once
okay it was trying to rewrite to the uh
the other tensorboard logs so i guess
we'll also say logs
and then we'll do this
logs slash
ppo
time.time
what did i screw up
ah
boom okay try that again
what i really want to see like it was
trying to overwrite each other so here
i'll show you what i what tipped me off
to that one
okay well
maybe it was this one
i might have made the logs a little
messy but yeah i saw logging to logs and
then it was just ppo underscore zero for
both of them obviously we don't want
that
um because then we'd have crazy logs so
hopefully we didn't totally murder well
we did
we murdered our other log but that's
okay um
that's all right
okay that one is running so i will run
one more uh ppo
and just to clean up the logs i will
come into here and i will delete maybe
we'll leave the original a2c but this
one's been ruined so i'll just delete it
and now what i'll do is i'll also add an
a2c
take that pasta pasta
a2c
a2c
i bet we could have fixed it with that
we could that would have been the more
proper place to fix it actually now that
i think about it we should have added
the time to that
uh i don't think it will be relevant
because it just doesn't it doesn't
really matter but this
we should have added the time stamp
right there
um whatever
i think we're fine
so let me check for ppo again
cool okay so now what i will do
we'll just run two more of these
python 3
p2
save
and i'm just going to open a tab
python 3 p2 save
let's check models make sure we're not
screwing ourselves there look very good
and then
we'll check logs
that's looking good so far
and then finally let's check
tensorboard
looking good looking good i wish i
didn't delete the original ppo
oof
whatever
okay
so
see if i can fit this on the screen
while it trains
very good very good
okay about an hour in
some change hour and 20 30 minutes or so
has gone by we are finally done training
everything here
and
um
interesting charts for sure
so checking out kind of the results it
does look like our best performer is
this ppo
model here
but also curiously i believe that's this
guy right here yeah so also curiously
where's the talk there it is
um
who's our second best here see like our
second best was like sort of even this
like a2c for a second that for the
original one that i said was really good
for an a2c model
by the way um
that was actually our second or our uh
second best for a little bit and then it
appears that it kind of went bad oh well
that was the well that was the one that
we trained for only 300k steps
um but then it's another a2c model
that was actually pretty good for a
little bit and then yes it throws it all
away just just like the other one was
clearly going to do in it and it never
recovered
but by the end uh the the two victors
here are ppo
and ppo so if you can use ppo use ppo
it seems to be the best one that i've
you know at least in my experience of
using in in all fairness a2c i don't
know anybody that's still using a2c for
anything specific but anyways um yeah so
we have our results we've compared
models um you've seen now
real examples of how
that random initialization can make all
the all the difference um so again you
might want to actually explicitly set
your random seed possibly or just simply
train a handful of models
in my opinion i would just again i would
just kind of randomly train a few models
and
then whichever one is going well
continue training that model i don't i
don't really see any statistical reason
why you want to set like random seed 0
for example for all the algorithms that
you test
because
in theory you might be you know maybe
you were that that bad ppo from before
uh when really you could have been you
could have been good ppo if you would
have allowed that seed to you know come
across your desk so anyways uh let's
check out one of these ppos so it looks
like um maybe around here is one of the
better ones
so we are where we step
so let's do the 550k ppo so let's check
that one out so p2c p2 load uh i already
know i've i gotta figure out what was
the uh
550 000
and which
before i forget so let's see pb
let me change this to be ppo
um
and which one was that ppo
uh is there a way i can just
yes
i'll do that
maybe
cool
come over here
paste
i think we can get away with that with
the models there
we'll save that
let's run that and see if that works
beautiful look at it look at it go
yeah so yeah that's uh probably solved
we'll look at a few more but i would say
at this point yes that is indeed
um
that is indeed solved so the other thing
that i wouldn't mind checking real
quickly while that continues to play
is what was our best a2c it looks like
a2c like our original a2c is is the best
one that went for 300 000 steps
so
the a2c at about
not quite 200k steps but maybe 190.
yeah
so a2c0 at 190k looked pretty good so
let me
um
i guess i'll move this over here you can
watch that and we'll just check it out
so a2z
a
2c
0.
is that going to be right for the
modelster let me check that
that'd be right for the logs but for
models yeah it's just a2c
i already forgot what i said was it 190k
okay so this is our a2c um
yeah i mean it's not
it's not quite as good as the ppo it did
learn at least
but at least for sure on this
environment i see no reason to use it
ppo is faster
and ppo is better so hopefully now
you've got an even better understanding
of reinforcement learning stable
baselines three and you're coming to
grips with how do you change your
algorithms and all that now up to this
point we've been using these pre-made
environments and like i've been saying
the really true hard thing is to figure
out which environment do you want to use
ppo on
so so
i'm just kidding there are other
algorithms and obviously ppo is no good
for there is continuous ppo but again we
will we'll talk more i promise after the
custom environments we will talk more
about uh continuous versus uh discrete
and all that kind of stuff um but i
think the next best thing to do is i
think anybody is getting into
reinforcement learning if you're not
just doing it just for the kicks
is you want to apply this to your own
environment so in the coming videos what
i'm going to do is we'll just take some
environment i can find online um i'm
thinking some sort of pie game game or
something like that convert that to
a
a gym environment so show you kind of
the steps that are involved to do that
and then actually train a model in that
environment again because this is an
environment that we're going to have to
make up
the observations so
you'll see that it's not you know in
this case we've just been handed
observations so how do you come up with
your own quality observations how do you
start thinking in that way and then also
how to come up with your rewards because
again these two things are actually
deceptively
complicated sometimes so
i think i think you'll see a few good
examples as we as we go through that so
anyways that's all for now thanks for
watching and i will see you guys in
another video
you